tu es avec deux nouveaux invités
d'ailleurs bonjour pierre haski
bienvenue vous êtes fondateur de rue89
chroniqueur international et
géopolitique sur france inter on signale
votre dernier livre géopolitique de la
chine et on rappelle que vous êtes
également président de reporters sans
frontières à vos côtés l'un des plus
grands savants français merci pierre
henri gouyon d'être avec nous vous êtes
professeur alors j'en ai retenu certains
je ne vous ai fait pas tous parce que
sinon on aura besoin de toutes les
missions sciences po normale sup le
muséum d'histoire naturelle le
spécialiste de génétique et vous
présidez notamment le conseil
scientifique du think tank de la
fondation hulot
face à vous guilhemery bonjour historien
journaliste et directeur de la
publication de causeur qui fait sa une
sur notre confrère et ami eric zemmour a
que 7 vous alexandre de vécu aux
journalistes à figaro vox hauteur on ne
le répétera jamais assez des nouveaux
enfants du siècle
c'était en 2016 auxerre et qui se met de
plus en plus à la cravate mais ce soir
qui est resté et mélenchonistes on
reviendra justement à la fin de
l'émission sur cette question de la
cravate et de l'info ce sera après la
question que tout le monde se pose ce
soir et aujourd'hui en allemagne merkel
doit-elle quitter la chancellerie avant
c'est l'avis des libéraux allemands la
chancelière en tous les cas renonce à
briguer un nouveau mandat à la tête de
la cd ou après une nouvelle déconvenue
de son parti hier lors d'une élection
régionale dans le land de hesse à
l'étranger encore une autre question
faut-il s'inquiéter de l'élection de
rahim also know
c'est la question qu'on vous pose sur
twitter le nouveau président brésilien
veut baisser l'âge de la responsabilité
pénale il regrette la dictature
militaire et il veut amplifier
l'exploitation de l'amazonie donnez nous
votre avis posez nouveau question on
restera sur le continent américain pour
revenir sur deux affaires récentes
l'envoi de colis piégés à plusieurs
autres responsabilité américaine et la
tuerie antisémite de pittsburgh samedi
les adversaires de trump met en cause la
rhétorique du président américain
ont-ils raison ont-ils tort partagez
vous leur avis en tous les cas vous
pouvez nous donner votre point de vue et
puis vous pouvez également nous dire si
vous regrettez beaucoup passionnément à
la folie ou pas du tout les années
philippe gildas etes-vous chasse au
trésor les nuls nulle part ailleurs où
virevolta on attend vos souvenirs vos
réponses ce sera en fin d'émission mais
d'abord direction berlin avec cette info
qui est tombée en milieu de matinée qui
a été confirmée quelques heures après
par angela merkel elle-même la baisse à
6,2 fut alors en cause les déconvenues
électorales de la cdo uns sont partis en
s 27% il recueillait hier 10 points de
moins qu'en 2013 c'est pire résultat
local depuis 1966 et l'allier
social-démocrate subit lui aussi vous le
voyez un énorme camoufler moins 10
points aussi alors il ya une question
qui se pose pierre haski je me tourne
vers vous est-ce qu'il est patent en
tirer les conséquences et de convoquer
de nouvelles élections
ce serait à mon avis un peu prématurée
parce que oui mondissa de l'élection de
plus depuis un mois on disait à chaque
fois ces réactions l'élection a été
tenue ya à peine un an dispose toujours
d'une majorité tant que sa coalition
tient elle a pas de raison de les
convoquer simplement je pense que même
si elle a dit qu'elle resterait jusqu'en
moi je suis papa à parier que y aura des
élections anticipées en allemagne et
qu'elle ne tiendra pas jusqu'en 2021
quelqu'un qui annonce son départ ne peut
pas tenir deux années de plus
voilà c'est ce que les
avec un appel line dax est à dire voilà
on est devenu un canard boiteux
parce qu'on n'a plus d'autorité à partir
du moment où tout le monde sait que vous
êtes sur le départ ce qui est
intéressant dans cette affaire c'est que
c'est pas un problème de désaveu
d'angela merkel ce qui est en train de
se passer c'est un séisme beaucoup plus
large c'est que ce sont les vieux partis
politiques qui sont en train de perdre
du terrain partout si vous prenez les
élections italiennes françaises et
allemandes les trolleys dans les trois
pays vous avez le même phénomène
les grands partis historiques sont en
train de s'écrouler alors en allemagne
s'est plus mesuré ce qu'ils sont quand
même encore en dominant la cd ou arrive
en tête dans le land de hesse même si
elle a perdu 11 points en france et en
italie
les partis historiques se sont
véritablement écroulé et c'est ça qui
est important
on s'est focalisé sur la montée on va
peut-être venir justement sur sur sa sur
le fait de la montée de l'extrême droite
est peut-être la montée des écologistes
dans un deuxième temps mais juste vous
dites et je voudrais avoir la réaction
de guy milis sur cette question ce n'est
pas un désaveu d'engrais merkel c'est
votre avis également guide je pense que
c'est en quelque sorte oui on ne vaut
pas personnellement parce que c'est pas
c'est pas une personnalité qui ce site
l'antagonisme ont la haine mais c'est un
élan quand quelque chose il faut il faut
pas oublier non plus que la seule chose
que les journaux produisent c'est pas
des bonnes décisions
c'est la légitimité c'est la seule chose
et c'est tout ce qu'on demande
or on voit que le gouvernement allemand
est en perte de légitimité et angéla
merkel qui étant un animal politique de
très très haut niveau
elle sait ce qu'on a dit tout à l'heure
c'est une évidence quand on annonce son
départ
le compte à rebours commence c'est
elle-même qui a théorisé il ya quinze
ans je pense les liens entre la
présidence de ces deux et être
chancelier
donc elle comprend tout à fait ce
qu'elle vient de dire et laisse le temps
pour la
le concours
là pour chercher pour chercher chercher
un successeur succès en successeur mais
pas de suppression il ya un désaveu est
né ce qui est intéressant ce qui est
intéressant c'est par rapport aux autres
dégagisme c'est pour c'est pour une
seule question c'est pour la question de
l'immigration c'est pour la sole et
c'est l'unique question qu'on appelle
identitaire ce que je disais que je
disais ce n'est pas un désaveu de merkel
sait que je pense que il ya dans cette
affaire c'est au delà de la personnalité
de merkel est paradoxalement dans les
sondages elle reste très haut un niveau
personnel c'est à dire que l est placé
beaucoup plus haut que son propre parti
dont il ya il ya quelque chose de
structurel dans cette danse eu cet
effondrement des partis historiques qui
effectivement le détonateur c'est la
crise des migrants c'est 2015
mais regardez là pourquoi la cs ou qui
en bavière après une ligne totalement
anti merkel a refusé qu'elle vienne
faire campagne et a fait venir le
chancelier autrichien à la place faire
un score aussi mauvais que la cd ou dans
le land de hesse c'est agir soit pas
crédible
oui mais c'est plus compliqué que ça je
sais que c'est la fin d'une époque
globalement kiki qui prend des formes
variées selon les pays mais on est en
train de vivre un changement d'époque et
on vient de voir des chiffres on va vers
alexandre ii vecchio pour vous c'est pas
un désaveu de merkel je suis assez
d'accord avec ce qu'a dit pierre haski
je pense que ça des traces le mossad et
pas seulement censuré salle gantois de
la grande coalition
justement ça dépasse la personnalité
dont angela merkel et je pense que c'est
l'effet de la grande coalition
finalement quand tous les partis se
ressemblent il ne se distingue plus et
il n'y a plus d'alternative possible si
ce n'est celle des partis
10/10 populiste est nouveau et c'est ce
qui est en train de se passer en
allemagne je dirais qu'en france on est
peut-être moins avancés puisque macro
n'a pas fait de coalition puisque le
système électoral mais pas le même mais
on est aussi dans une forme de coalition
entre libéraux de gauche et libéraux de
droite donc cesser cette impasse la dans
laquelle on l'est l'afd n'est pas
capable d'être une alternative crédible
pour le moment et donc on voit pas très
bien comment l'allemagne va sortir de la
crise c'est ça qui est intéressant c'est
pour ça qu'elle dit je me représenterai
pas effectivement c'est la démo et
monétise totalement politiquement je
vois pas comment elle peut gouverner
après cela mais il n'ya pas que
tellement d'alternative en allemagne
aujourd'hui à merkel donc donc on va
avoir manqué une scission à l'intérieur
de son propre parti avec une droite qui
redeviennent a réellement de droite
en tout cas
après la disparition de la
social-démocratie la droite paie très
cher c'est alliance centriste molle
libéral contre nature autre côté il
n'était pas lié avec les numéros pour
l'instant pierre henri gouyon on voit en
revanche les verts gagnent bi poin
encore une hausse après donc la
performance d'il ya 15 jours en bavière
est ce que le président du conseil
scientifique du think tank est la
fondation s'appelle fondation pour la
nature et l'homme puisqu'on peut pas
avoir un ministre dans une fondation bon
avec moi qui ai plein ministre y
parvenant à prendre pour elle il va
brader la croissance donc en tout cas
bien sûr moi je me réjouis du bon score
des verts allemands bien que justement
je je pense que quand on est dans un
système complexe comme les systèmes
politiques nationaux ou internationaux
il ya toujours une pluralité de cause
dans chaque et chaque fai qui se produit
et il ya des causes plus proches et des
causes plus globale et 5 intéressant
dans la discussion convient d'avoir
c'est que tout compte fait les causes
globales elles sont sur la chute des
grands partis et ça c'est un truc qui
probablement est liée à une ambiance
globale de deux de nos nations avec
peut-être effectivement une ressemblance
de plus en plus grande entre les partis
de gouvernement qui fait que au compte
fait les gens finissent par se demander
si ça va voir en la peine d'aller en
choisir un ou l'autre avec le système
néolibéral qui donne de plus en plus
l'impression que le pouvoir n'est pas
dans les mains des politiques mais dans
les mains des financiers avec
l'appauvrissement des états les états
n'ont plus d'argent si vous prenez les
actifs de l'allemagne ou de la france et
puis que vous enlevez les dettes et
baisse quasiment rien et l'argent et
donc chez des gens qui ne sont pas les
dirigeants politiques je pense que tout
ça fait que les grands partis ne donne
plus l'impression de pouvoir gouverner
et que du coup on cherche autre chose
alors après bah tant mieux si les
allemands ont choisi les verts
malheureusement dans d'autres cas encore
parlé du brésil il ya des cas où le
choix est bien moins bon que sa mémé et
du coup certainement les migrants joue
un rôle dans cette affaire mais je suis
pas sûr qu'ils jouent un rôle si
fondamental parce que si jamais il
n'était pas là il y aurait autre chose
parce que pour faire que ça marche pas
justement si on va jusqu'au bout
on voit quand même l'augmentation
également enfin même pas l'augmentation
l'afd qui fait sens quasiment son
apparition à son entrée au parlement de
hesse est ce que justement ça valide pas
et je vais un petit peu plus loin que ce
que vous évoquez ou 2007
cette émission est ce que ça valide pas
l'analyse de macron entre un nouveau une
nouvelle césure on va vers une nouvelle
session entre progressistes qui serait
incarnée par les verts et souverainistes
et populiste entre l'effondrement des
uns et la montée des cieux que je ne
crois pas que ce soit ça la lecture de
ces élections en allemagne pourrait
traduire un peu plus de complexité dans
notre conversation parce que moi j'aime
beaucoup ça est ce que vous savez que
les verts sont restés avec nous
est ce que vous savez que les verts sont
au gouvernement du land de hesse en
alliance avec la cd ou et ça c'est quand
même le truc formidable c'est que si
c'était un désaveu des modes de
gouvernement en allemagne aujourd'hui
tous les partis qui sont au pouvoir et
là en l'occurrence vous repensez la
région que c'est comme disait notre
consoeur hélène colle un rejet de la
grosse coalition
si si moi je pense que la grosse que la
gauche coalition a vécu elle a fait son
temps et en a sans doute une de trop
aujourd'hui et c'est ce qui a été tenté
au début par merkel après sa
contre-performance de septembre l'année
dernière et qui n'a pas réussi qui est l
alliance jamaïque comme on l'appelait
c'est-à-dire cd ou libéraux et verts et
était peut-être aurait peut-être été une
meilleure formule pour redonner du
souffle à la gouvernance de merkel que
de reprendre les mêmes avec des spd qui
n'en voulait pas initialement qui
pensait qu'il lui fallait une cure
d'opposition pour se refaire une santé
et qui finalement a voté pour entre
guillemets sauver l'europe et là on est
on est dans une situation aujourd'hui où
effectivement merkel elle a deux choix
soit elle recompose sa coalition
effectivement elle essaye de nouveau
avec les verts et le fdp donc les
libéraux et là on a une nouvelle
configuration et elle peut espérer
tenir un petit peu plus longtemps soit
elle elle va autant de temps que le spd
reste au pouvoir avec elle
et puis il y aura des élections
anticipées dans un an dans deux heures
puisque vous parlez d'europe pardon avec
centre je vous coupe mais je vous donne
la parole juste après on puisque vous
parliez d'europe merkel s'est exprimée à
plusieurs reprises sur le sujet sur les
défis qui représente l europe et ça
correspond également à une certain
nombre de sujets qui sont soulevées par
nos internautes on va y revenir dans un
instant je vous propose d'écouter la
chancelière
c'était au mois de juin dernier alors on
a beaucoup parlé sur la nouvelle
configuration politique mais on est un
peu exploré ce sujet de l'immigration
quand on lit juste en ce qu'ils disent
les internautes je pense à henri
notamment la chancelière dépassé les
bornes sur plusieurs sujets qui concerne
non seulement les allemands mais
l'europe des 28 d'abord sur
l'immigration l'europe va-t-elle subir
les conséquences de cette crise
politique en allemagne c'est ce que nous
demande johan merkel doit démissionner
c'est un échec personnel c'est ce que
nous dit un autre internaute
elle paye le million et plus d'illégaux
en europe c'est ce que dit également sur
twitter depuis cet après midi quand on a
posé la question j'ai rome notamment qui
dit c'est la fin tant attendu dans gala
réfugie welcome est ce que elle ne paye
pas quand même ses choix en matière
migratoire
je pense qu'effectivement c'est
incontestable mais moi je lui tire mon
chapeau je pense que en 2015 elle a eu
une réaction absolument honorable et
elle a fait ce qu'il fallait faire et je
pense que si merkel avait fait comme
orba ne mette des barbelés aux
frontières ça aurait été la honte de
l'europe je défend cette position je
sais qu'elle ne sera peut-être pas très
populaire parmi vos internautes
mais c'est votre point de vue et c'est
bien on va dire le pro portage le point
de vue de jean meyali essai d'alexandre
de lecture alors oui prendra également
d'abord rappelons qu'elle est au pouvoir
depuis 13 ans et peut-être même elle
fera presque 14 ski à ce qui est pas mal
pour moi surtout pour un démocratie
parlementaire avec des gouvernements de
des coalitions qu'il ya aussi parmi la
longue la longue liste de raisons il ya
aussi derrière une jeune génération qui
commence à s'impatienter donc ça pousse
de tous les côtés bougez bougez vous
bougez vous dit si quand même
elles n'étaient pas tendres caen n'est
qu'à son tour est arrivé savez savez
comment faire alors pour revenir sur la
question de l'immigration je pense que l
été des vents choix impossible elles
étaient des vins choix impossible en
quelque sorte
les migrants étaient déjà là la question
n'était pas qu'est ce qu'on fait on les
laisse venir au pas il était déjà entre
la grèce et la frontière allemande dans
une sorte de chaos impossible en plus
c'était l'été il y avait personne pour
s'en occuper globalement et donc il
était elle était devant un choix
impossible mais sans change pas
le fait la question fondamentale c'est
que c'était la goutte d'eau c'était la
goutte d'eau non moi je crois que c'est
quand même mis dans cette situation-là
un peu tout seul on se souvient que ça
elle a pris sa décision après les images
du petit et l'amener sur une décision
lié à l'émotion et puis en plus elle a
dit jacques oeil sur une place sur une
plage et en plus elle a dit j'accueille
un million de milles euros
venez elle a créé un appel d'air et
effectivement elle a obligé viktor orban
à protéger les frontières de l'europe
donc elle a fait les choses d'une
manière à mon avis voilà dans le sur une
réaction émotionnelle et pas du tout en
faisant preuve de réalisme politique ça
aurait pu être géré beaucoup plus
calmement sans créer d'appel d'après sur
le contexte global en europe mais j'ai
quand même une pensée pour deux
personnes
aujourd'hui quand je vois les résultats
des élections c'est premièrement
emmanuel macron qui voulaient refonder
le rough faire une europe souveraine
basée sur le couple franco allemand on
voit que le couple franco allemand est
mort et qui sait gérer peut-être de
trouver d'autres alliances et puis une
pensée pour laurent wauquiez qui a
toujours autant d'impulsion politique et
qui effectivement assez il ya pa très
bouton un voyage pour aller voir madame
merkel la femme forte de l'europe
je crois que ça t'a dit aussi les choses
sur les vieux partis politiques à quel
point je ne comprenne pas le contexte
actuel mon chat à la cuisse en point
peut-être qui a été oublié dans cette
discussion c'est c'est qu'on est des
animaux et qu'on se reproduit et que la
démographie d'une population c'est
quelque chose et que la démographie
allemande comme tout le monde le sait
est catastrophique que actuellement le
taux de naissances est bien insuffisant
pour maintenir une population allemande
avec une pyramide d'âge raisonnable et
que donc je pense que sur le long terme
il est clair que l'allemagne ne pourra
pas se passer d'accepter des migrants
pour pour avoir un fonctionnement
démographique convenable et ça ça fait
partie à mon avis des données du
problème qui sont on parle que des
aspects humanitaires etc
je pense que ces aspects là peuvent pas
tenir bien henri gouyon je vous renvoie
à une excellente émission qui a été fait
ici c'est
justement les annonces autour d un an de
l'élection dans gayda merkel est
précisément quelqu'un de l'ifri expliqué
que le patronat allemand est revenu de
cette idée notamment sur la démographie
allemande vient joueront le débat
continue on va pas d'épuiser ici je cite
la dernière phrase de nos internautes
henri paul qui explique ce qui arriva
merkel n'est pas un cas isolé
le pouvoir pen partout à communiquer sur
ses actions on vous pose également la
question sur twitter et vous avez vu la
réponse sur le fait que merkel doit
partir ou non l'autre question qu'on
nous pose sur twitter est ce qu'il faut
s'inquiéter de l'élection de jaillir
ball sorano au brésil 55,13 % donc c'est
ce chiffre ce score qui marque un
tournant dans l'histoire du brésil et
qui marque l'élection de jaillir
bolsenheim
voici une de ses toutes premières
réactions c'était cette nuit je vous
propose d'écouter les beghdadi est un
principe fondamental
liberta jédir et vire 1 dans la zone est
organisée par les berda jnpr liberdade
politiques et religieuses les bernaches
dufour mal et l opinion
libertad jeune escouade et c'est
respectable pour les races et si on
parlait plutôt de noise bras célèbre n'a
tous ont dû collation voilà c'est ball
sonar haut il faut être précis et je
remercie aziliz le corps qui m'a corrigé
savourer sur ce que vous venez
d'entendre guy demel éclaté il a déjà
bon
pour essayer de mettre les choses dans
une contexte un petit peu plus large au
moins depuis 1930
au brésil il ya des époques deux ou
trois décennies de démocratie plus ou
moins libéral avec deux ou trois
décennies de dictature de régimes
autoritaires donc il y avait vargas
après il y avait la deuxième république
entre 45 et 64 avec un retour des orgas
au milieu avec un histoire rocambolesque
à la boulanger et après on a là la
nouvelle république
le problème
le brésil c'est d'une banalité
affligeante c'est que c'est toujours un
pays d'avenir toujours toujours en plus
d'avenir
depuis très longtemps c'est toujours
l'avenir ils n'arrivent pas à contourner
le problème de fond ils sont liés au
développement économique et social de
ces pays
ils ont toujours deux des élites sont
qui restent à peu près les mêmes avec
les mêmes genres de problèmes politiques
et donc sonné dans on est dans une
longue série de deux des hauts et des
bas et lomme qui est qui vient de gagner
les élections c'est un c'est un grand
mystère parce que pour aller vite c'est
un yack à faire c'est s'il a des
solutions pour tous il est très peu
probable que s'il met en exécution ce
qu'il a dit ça peut pas aller trop loin
mais on peut jamais exclure les faits
que l'on gouverne pas seul qu'il a pas
le contrôle de parlement que justement
il ya un certain nombre des lits étaient
en force et en fonction publique un
fossé en public et est donc en fait tout
est possible les pires comme je dirais
pas le meilleur mais comme le pas mal
alors justement quand même avec cette
migration historique je vous remercie
donc je rappelle que vous êtes un
brillant historien diplômé diplômé de
l'université de la ville pierre s qui
est ce que justement quand on entend
l'inédit et on peut lire également ce
que dit avec centre sur twitter son
élection on peut avoir deux issues une
dégradation des relations
internationales où un appel à se
réveiller contre les idées extrémistes
est-ce qu'on a quand même pas un peu
peur avant d'avoir mal non je ne crois
pas parce que enfin cet homme a une
histoire
je sais combien je suis provocateur oui
cette dame a une histoire des plus à
libé le jour le jour le jour où dilma
rousseff a été destitué au parlement
brésilien bolton araud a dit qu'il dédié
son vote à l'homme qui a torturé des
dilma rousseff lorsqu'elle était
militante contre la dictature
c'est un homme qui a une histoire cette
ses déclarations à l'emporte-pièce
disant qu'ils préféreraient tué son fils
plutôt que que d'apprendre qu'il était
gay enfin on peut les multiplier on les
connaît le florilège de ses déclarations
donc moi je veux bien que tout ça soit
du cinéma et que une fois élu il
prononcé 14 fois le mot liberté dans son
discours bon ça c'est du bon spin c'est
un spin doctor c'est ça c'est d'un
conseiller en com qui lui a écrit son
discours et pour rassurer la communauté
internationale
moi je pense que les premiers qui ont à
s'inquiéter c'est évidemment les
brésiliens parce que il ya du rodrigo
doutèrent dans cet homme sert le
président des philippines qui a mené une
guerre contre la drogue et lui veut
mener une guerre contre la criminalité
qui s'est traduite par des milliers
d'exécutions sommaires aux philippines
par une presse qui a été totalement
muselée là je parle en tant que reporter
sans frontières on a un partenaire aux
philippines qui est un média qui a été
totalement piétiné par par le
gouvernement de duterte et et et on peut
craindre la même chose au vu des
déclarations qu'il a faites
la deuxième crainte qu'on peut avoir et
qu'on doit légitimement avoir mais là
c'est en tant que que citoyen du monde
c'est pour l'amazonie pour
l'environnement alors on va on va y
revenir c'est quand même on va y revenir
dans un deuxième temps mais juste on va
rester sur ces sur ces questions là et
sur les premiers signaux qui ont été
envoyées par son élection
alexandre ii vecchio
je vois ce que nous dit un homme nos
internautes geppetto qui dénonce le fait
que les élites sont contre trump contre
bolton arrow et dont contre l'avis
volonté exprimée du peuple ça je je le
vois on peut effectivement comprendre ce
qu écrit cet internaute
d'un autre côté quand on voit les
militaires en treillis uniforme célébrer
cette élection dans les rues comme on
l'a vu cette nuit on n'est pas forcément
rassuré non moi je suis je suis très
très partagés sur cette histoire bon
d'abord je m'incline devant le suffrage
universel
on peut être d'accord ou pas d'accord
avec ball sonar ou maintenant il a été
élu et l'udemo démocratiquement
ceci étant dit je pense pour le coup qui
a des raisons s'inquiéter on dit la
volonté du peuple
mais dans pour le coup c'est plus
compliqué que ça allait aussi beaucoup
comparé aux populistes comme trump comme
salvini je suis pas sûr que ce soit la
même chose d'ailleurs il a été quand
même
défendu par me les les milieux
financiers les milieux économiques donc
c'est pas totalement le même candidat du
peuple que les autres populaire puisque
son électorat éplucher les classes
aisées que celle et les classes
populaires alors c'est maintenant une
journaliste brésilienne qui était
invitée de l'écrit peur disait qu' il y
avait à la fois et olivier compagnon qui
est l'un des responsables de l'institut
des hautes études d'amérique d'amérique
latine à la sorbonne nouvelle disait que
à la fois c'était les classes aisées qui
l'avait portée mais une partie des
classes populaires
une partie des classes populaires qui
sans doute ont été séduits par le
discours d'ordre celle ci l'a été élu
c'est avant tout parce que c'est un pays
miné par une insécurité folk il ya 4000
parlant il ya un besoin d'ordre dans le
pays mais faut quand même revenir il ya
je pense que c'est l'un des facteurs
principaux
mais les conditions rocambolesques de
7,2 cette élection je rappelle quand
même que dilma rousseff a été destitué
pour des questions budgétaires on dit
pour des questions de corruption c'est
pas vrai elle a été destituée parce que
elle avait maquillé le déficit
budgétaire donc voilà d'une elle a été
remplacée par le président des maires
qui est tombée quand même à s'il devait
se présenter là ils étaient 1 %
d'intentions de vote qui a fait une
politique néolibérale complètement folle
je l'en le budget pour pour 25 ans des
privatisations à outrance on compte
quand on a le gouvernent ensuite lula
qui avait sorti quand même 30 millions
de personnes de la pauvreté qui était le
grandissime favori je le rappelle de
l'élection qui aurait sans doute gagné
au premier tour s'il avait pu se
présenter
donc quand on a le gouvernement des
juges sont des années grenoble a pas eu
il était inconnu et s'est présenté à la
dernière minute donc je rappelle que les
partis de centre-droit el centre gauche
qui sont à l'origine de cette
destitution était balayée dès le premier
toit là encore une fois donc quand on a
le gouvernement des juges des comptables
et des technocrates et bat le peuvent le
peuple se venger faut pas s'étonner de
ce résultat électoral la maintenance est
plus inquiétant qu'ailleurs puisque le
brésil n'est pas les états unis
effectivement comme l'a rappelé qu'il y
là il est sorti de la dictature
seulement 85 et effectivement je pense
que le programme de golf now est
beaucoup plus inquiétant que ce qu'on
voit chez les populismes européen après
ce réquisitoire quasi chavistes 2
alexandre avec les deux vecchio
justement je voulais avoir l'avis de
[Musique]
gilles à l'ouest il alors existe
justement pierre henri gouyon avant de
revenir peut-être éventuellement sur ce
que chavez a représentant en tout cas le
venezuela représentés dans cette
campagne
l'exploitation de l'amazonie tels que la
prom est telle que la promeut
ball sonar ou j'imagine que ça vous
inquiète ah oui ça ça nous inquiète ça
nous inquiète
ça nous inquiète entre autres parce que
bolton arora proposa au brésil
mais quand on voit déjà ce qui se passe
en argentine avec les immenses surfaces
cultivées en soja transgénique désherber
en avion avec une seule une seule
variété sur des millions d'hectares
bien sûr qu'il ya de quoi s'inquiéter a
de quoi s'inquiéter à deux points de vue
d'une part la disparition d'une entité
écologique très importante donc qui est
cette forêt amazonienne qui pour le
moment n'est encore le coup
contrairement à la forêt vous ferez de
java à bornéo et ses acquis qui ont
toutes les chances de disparaître
complètement d'ici pas très longtemps là
il y avait encore quand même un gros
réservoir et c'est sûr que si le brésil
le brésil attaque violemment la forêt ça
sera une très grosse perte on peut
difficilement prédire quelles sont les
conséquences exactes de la disparition
d'une partie importante de cette forêt
ça va changer plein de choses y compris
le cycle du carbone parce que l'amazone
emporté beaucoup de carbone produit par
la photosynthèse des plantes dans
l'océan ça va changer les termes de
biodiversité ça va changer en termes de
climat plus ou moins local
ça va changer énormément de choses non
c'est pas tout près dire à l'heure
actuelle et puis ça va changer aussi sur
le plan agricole parce que évidemment
c'est cette forêt sera remplacé par de
l'agriculture intensive à forte dose
d'intrants extrêmement homogène et donc
on va encore perdre de la diversité dans
l'est dans le milieu agricole
j'assiste à tulle pendant l'été
quand même avait soutenu également un
certain nombre d'initiatives qui était
contraire à l'environnement alors lula a
beaucoup évolué dans son dans son
attitude puisque quand il est arrivé il
était fort défenseur d'une agriculture
durable etc
et il a eu besoin d'argent et ceux qui
le pétrin bras si l'état ne vois là
aussi il ya eu et puis il ya eu des
entreprises qui lui ont proposé de
l'argent contre le fait accepter leurs
produits des entreprises d'agro et de
semences et donc effectivement il a ses
idées j'ai entendu tout ce que vous avez
dit contre bolton arolla c'était une
amie une unanimité encore allemande
guillaume naudi en revanche les
intérieurs sont sûrement d'accord avec
vous dit guillaume ledit après les
années lula et rousseff c'est sûrement
un virage vers plus de netteté la
sécurité nécessaire au brésil nous dit
henri paul doucette élections les
prémices de la situation française bon
c'est un point de vue et nicole nous dit
mais c'est un point de vue en tout cas
qu'on entend c'est insupportable cette
façon de déniant la volonté des peuples
quand ça ne plaît pas l'establishment
cesse que de nikon je pense que l'esprit
la régulière il est tout à fait légitime
ici ne conteste la légitimité de cette
élection c'est pas la question n'est pas
là la question elle est d'analyser les
conséquences et les ressorts de cette
élection
et là je veux dire moi j'ai
effectivement je fais mon édito ce matin
sur france inter là dessus et je me suis
fait attaquer sur le thème vous
n'acceptez pas le résultat quand il vous
plaît pas moi je d'abord je ne suis pas
brésiliens je n'ai pas à accepter ou pas
le résultat des élections brésiliennes
et je ne le conteste pas je pense que
c'est une catastrophe pour les
brésiliens et accessoirement pour le
monde pour des raisons qui viennent
d'être évoqués
en revanche ce qui est intéressant c'est
que il ya une part d'universel dans
cette dans cette histoire et une part
locale dans l'histoire du brésil et dans
la sociologie est dans la réalité du
brésil il ya une part universelle c'est
que vous avez une classe politique qui
est qui s'est discréditée vautrer dans
la corruption le népotisme et l'incurie
et que l est désavoué et que bolton
arrow étaient le
l'homme qu'il fallait au moment où il
fallait pour ramasser la mise salut
réside pas atteint par là comme sûre
voilà de prêt sera décembre alexandre la
gauche brésilienne mais quand même
rappeler que c'est pas la gauche
brésilienne qui était au pouvoir ces
deux dernières années alors on aura
entendu en tout cas ce point de vue les
investissements et tout ça c'était la
gauche
on reviendra sur ces questions là on n'a
pas terminé c'est le 1er janvier que
j'allais rebelles sont nos prendra ses
fonctions comme nouveau président du
brésil
il a eu la félicitation les
félicitations cette nuit en tout cas
d'un autre président américain c'est
donald trump
le président américain qui est mise en
cause par une partie des médias
américains et internationaux pour ses
propos et s'arrête et sa rhétorique
surtout après deux affaires celle des
colis piégés et celle de la tuerie de
pittsburgh 29 chefs d'accusation ont été
retenus à l'encontre de robert bauer
l'auteur de la tuerie contre la
synagogue de l'arbre de vie à pittsburgh
samedi 11 morts au dernier bilan
on a entendu donald trump s'exprimer et
il a condamné l'acte est l'oeuvre d'un
cinglé guilluy délit c'est clair net et
sans appel
oui c'est un beau discours allez pour la
question en est ce que c'est la faute à
à donald rampe c'est ce que pendant ce
temps avant les battrons de
l'anti-defamation league
oui alors je pense que profond de mon
donald trump et en septembre de quelque
chose presque autant que cet assassinat
au haut que les 294 autres cas de deux
meurtres de masse aux états unis et
depuis depuis le début dès 2018
après une accalmie parce qu'il faut pas
oublier à quel point la société
américaine est violente et même les
années 60 que beaucoup regrettent il y
avait trois assassinats politiques
majeurs les deux kennedy et martin
luther king il y avait le sniper fou de
de texas avec 49 morts il y avait deux
il y avait des assassinats coranique je
recommande un trou le récit de leurs
mandeville dans le dans le figaro a
retrouvé qu'il est le début d'une longue
série sur justement des reportages en
pennsylvanie qu'il ya une ambiance de
guerre civile actuellement quand on est
simple pour ne pas aller plus loin les
50 40 30
c'était horrible il y avait une accalmie
entre les années 70 et les années 2000
qui s'est terminée probablement avec la
présidence d'obama et avec le
le tea party donc tout ce qui se passe à
partir de ce moment là et évidemment je
pense que profondément les choses sont
la raison profonde c'est le la fin la
mort lente de classe moyenne aux états
unis le changement de modèle économique
la mondialisation et donc il re polarise
évoquerait une tension puisqu'on alors
évidemment et je mets évidemment rapide
je pense que trempe n'a rien fait pour
calmer les jeux ça on peut le dire mais
il n'est pas responsable ce qu'une
pierre haski se trouve que moi je suis
revenue hier des états unis j'ai passé
toute la semaine dernière new york et
washington
et c'est frappant la polarisation
extrême qu'il ya dans ce pays
à côté de ça la france c'est les
bisounours c'est et donc vous avez une
situation où ce ne soit pas toujours été
que de savoir si elles s'étaient
franchement je crois pas je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on est dans une situation
où trump parle à sa base parce que le
discours qu'on a entendu qui est
magnifique c'est parce qu'il a dit les
deux premiers jours
ses premières réactions et notamment le
soir même de de la tuerie de pittsburgh
il avait un meeting électoral il a dit
qu'il avait failli annuler son meeting
parce qu'ils avaient une journée à
mauvais cheveux comme il dit cet homme
voilà aux yeux d'une partie de
l'amérique et sans foi ni loi et aux
yeux d'une autre partie de l'amérique
c'est l'autre partie qui est sans foi ni
loi et que et qui n'est pas crédible
il ya deux mondes totalement parallèle
qui se haïssent aujourd'hui on est on en
est à sa et donc moi je pense que c'est
mon profond oui c'est plus profond mais
c'est évident que donald trump et le
pompier pyromane dans cette affaire il y
joue en permanence à inciter à la
violence et lorsqu'elle se produit dit
on mais moi je suis pas responsable
de ce qui se passe on est on est et ça
ce n'est pas le seul à être dans ce cas
là quand même avec son nom c'est
excessif qui est une polarisation aux
etats unis c'est un sujet mais jamais
donald trump a appelé à tuer les gens à
tuer des juifs dont une dans une
synagogue
je crois que la personne en l'occurrence
qui on reprochait d'être trop
philosémite être aux mondialistes donc
il n'a pas voulu prendre parti entre les
néonazis et les antilles lassé des
contre manifestants beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus compliqué que ça donc je
crois qu'on mélange qu'on mélange de
choses il ya les le problème du port
d'armes aux états lui là il a une
responsabilité mais les démocrates ont
fait exactement la même chose avant et
il ya effectivement la question des
fractures américaine qu'on retrouve en
france de manière moins net mais avec
effectivement une amérique populaire en
amérique ouvrière une amérique du centre
qui proposait de plus en plus à
l'amérique des côtes et des grandes
métropoles et je crois qu'il ya des
responsabilités dans les deux sens si
cet électorat populaire et aussi raide
et radicalisée c'est parce qu'il a été
méprisée insulté par l'élite des côtes
depuis des années et souvenez-vous de
d'hillary clinton qui parle du panier
des déplorable et c'est pas que moi qui
le dit c'est mark lilla universitaires
américains en proche du parti démocrate
qui explique que ces étudiants on
considère que le centre de l'amérique
c'est quasiment une jungle et il n'y
aurait que s'il ya de plus dur pour eux
c'est d'aller prendre à un café tout
simplement dans un angle ces étapes pour
parler à l'amérique populaire donc je
crois que si donald trump a peut-être
radicaliser cet électorat là de nous
c'est valable dans l'autre sens et et
voilà il ya une guerre culturelle qui
est installée et fait effectivement il
faut que ces deux amériques finissent
par se parler mais j'ai autant peur du
mouvement me to qui est une une sorte de
nouveau maccarthysme et daf ministre par
exemple délieront que dès que des
failles de mais donald trump n'a pas
fait de noir était de ne se revendique
pas de donald trump il était en petite
forme cédant fou c'est marrant
c'est fou quand les gens qui se
revendiquent de l'est l'idéologie
islamiste par exemple viennent certaine
gauche qui nous explique c'est des fous
et là c'est un fou il n'a pas parlé de
donald trump est ici on n'est pas pris
d'ailleurs elle ce n'est pas pris à
l'élite de la côte est fin je vois pas
pourquoi vous politiser cette affaire là
donc je pense qu'on parle de deux choses
différentes qui est une guerre
culturelle aux états viennent et c'est
une chose qui est un problème de
violence qui existe depuis la naissance
de ce pays avec le port d'armes sans
mener une autre mais je crois qu'on peut
pas accuser donald trump de ski et de
voilà de cette histoire américaine
violente depuis toujours
donald trump s'est appuyé sur l'ordre
ait la dôle l extrême droite américaine
pour se faire élire il n'a jamais voulu
d avouer ni le ku klux klan ni les
néonazis de charlottesville et il a
laissé faire toute cette frange
l'instant il ya des lobbys
pro-israéliens qu'ont soutenu trump et
ils sont pas dans le truck
non mais ça ne dit pas que il n'ya que
lloyd wright il n'aurait pas été élu
s'il n'y avait que lloyd wright qui
l'avait qui l'avaient soutenu mais il
n'a jamais prononcé une parole pour
désavouer cette frange extrémiste de
plus en plus vocal aux états unis et
c'est pareil pour l'homme qui a envoyé
les colis piégés qui se baladait dans un
camion avec l effigie de donald trump
est ce que ça fait de trump un coupable
le fait non c'est sais mais c'est
toujours la même histoire
il s'est passé c'est pas celui qui
incitent à la violence par lorsque
lorsque donald trump dans les meetings
désigne les journalistes en disant
faites news machin etc
le jour où il y aura un journaliste qui
se fera à tabac c'est parce que ça
arrivera aux états unis il ya une telle
c'est chauffé à blanc aujourd'hui
donald trump durable moi j'ai jamais dit
qu'il fallait leur casser la figure
c'est toujours la même histoire on peut
se retrancher en disant j'ai rien à voir
avec tout ça et bolton arrow puisqu'on
parlait lui tout à l'heure exacte mais
pas son nom c'est la bascule c'est la
bombe samedi c'est la même histoire il
ya il ya des partisans belle soirée
conte qui ont tabassé une femme a des
défauts mais celui qui a été agressée
point ordre oui mais il y a
il ya une belle qui a qu'il est d'aider
des gens on ont creusé une croix gammée
sur le corps avec un couteau qui étaient
des partisans de bolton à rome il a dit
mais moi je peux rien faire si je ne
connais pas ces gens là on est toujours
dans cette belle histoire vous vous
créez un climat et ensuite vous n'avez
aucune responsabilité il ya un moment il
faut assumer aussi ses responsabilités
sociales le dit en réponse à la question
de 8 heures nancy le temps tous les
jours sur twitter en prenant les
théories du complot et on entend
régulièrement trump attise la haine et
la violence bch le dis en plus du tram
dashing on ne peut pas en faire le bouc
émissaire nicole nous dit les démocrates
ont décidé que trump était le diable et
tout ce qui arrive aux états unis est de
sa faute
on continuera bien sûr d'en parler
scientifique c'est le diable que fut
comment il traite la science la ja en
continuant à en parler et justement d'en
faire une émission sur le sur les
accords de paris en attendant je voulais
vous poser une dernière question c'est
si vous regrettez les années gildas
comment réussir à la télévision quand on
est petit breton avec de grandes
oreilles c'était le titre des mémoires
de philippe de gildas c'était difficile
d'échapper à la fois difficile également
d'échapper à une de ses émissions
l'animateur est mort ce week-end des
suites d'un cancer à 82 ans est parmi
les hommages de nombreux hommages
on a retenu celui de michel drucker
c'est à jérôme jacq qui disparaît on
sait que quelqu'un qui savait tout faire
qui était très très doué
un des rares très rares on les compte
sur les doigts d'une main cavard été un
brillant journaliste brillante ali m
patron un créateur et c'est l'homme le
plus polyvalent le plus éclectique que
j'aie jamais rencontré
j'allais le voir le picard n'y a pas si
longtemps il avait encore des choses à
nous dire 82 sont ces jeunes dans notre
métier maintenant bien eu en il n'avait
pas fait ou choix ya mille african de
belles émissions d' aventure vous garder
un souvenir à un hommage pour philippe
d'une basse moi je franchement je
retiens extrêmement peu la télévision
mais mais le peu pour ça que vous êtes
ici sur l'affairé et le peu que j'ai vu
de lui c'était plutôt sympathique mais
savait que c'était une époque qu'on est
nombreux à regretter
alors c'est normal on la regrette parce
qu'on était plus jeune déjà
ni plus rien mais ce qui est terrifiant
c'est que les jeunes regrette cette
époque là qu'ils n'ont pas connue et ça
moi je trouve ça très triste parce que
on a une jeunesse actuelle qui te compte
faire regrette une époque en ayant
l'impression que nous l'a vécu l'âge
d'or et qu' ils n'ont plus d'ansé la
question du passé mais moi j'étais petit
quand vous êtes pour le coup c'est mon
enfance c'était quand canal+ était était
en clair et où effectivement peut-être
que vous je vais vous faire parce que
vous dites sur le vieux monde au nouveau
et je suis plus nulle part ailleurs que
le petit jaune ville à l'orage oui
c'était un homme d'idées c'est à dire à
la radio et les nouvelles à la télé ils
innover et se pense que c'est toute une
génération qui nous manque parce que si
on regarde et la radio et la télé ça
fait très longtemps qui a pas de format
révolutionnaire qu'on n'arrive pas à
renouveler que tout est en train de la
telle est en train de mourir
c'est les autres à mourir et on est on
est raciste et au seul web exactement
exactement donc pour moi il appartient à
cette génération ça durait entre 50 et
90 2000 où la france foisonner d'idées
des formats et qui a révolutionné les
médias moi j'avoue que j'ai peu de
souvenirs personnels de gildas que j'ai
cette phase c'était des années que je ne
sais pas où j'étais mais en tout cas
j'ai pas regardé une barrière et j'ai
adoré voir les lecteurs l'étranger et
j'aurais adoré voir les rétrospectives
depuis qu'il est qu'il a disparu et qui
était plutôt sympathique c'est à dire
que voilà c'est c'est c'est ce sont des
émissions est un personnage qui me
semblait sympathique ce qui n'est pas
toujours le cas des des animateurs de
télévision
alors ce que dit le commentaire la
relève n'arrive pas à sa cheville
hanoune ardisson ruquier moi je trouve
que le commandait arrête un peu vache
entre lieberman à la question entre les
nuls nulle part ailleurs la chasse aux
trésors la tête et les jambes
est-ce que vous avez une préférence
pierre henri gouyon je les connais pas a
dit pas vous ne connaissez pas la chasse
aux trésors et philippe de dieuleveult
vous avez pris pour quelqu'un de bien
vacher désole me posais pas la question
j'ai fait la même réponse que vous étiez
en chine la chine de mao
voilà exactement j'avais lu la tt
legends
c'est nulle part ailleurs qui est
également plébiscité manche voudrez pas
menti en lui disant que c'était pour ma
part la chasse aux trésors et hommages
et grands souvenirs à philippe de
dieuleveult qu'il a incarné le film de
la ville à face immatériel du vivant ses
looks frage collectif corps commandes et
c'est celui que vous avez écrit qu écrit
pierre henri gouyon essais chez odile
jacob shaw disent merci beaucoup et
merci de vos éclairages le dernier
numéro de closer il est consacré à eric
zemmour le prochain les pros chance et
sur les livres autour d'eux avait
l'ombre qui se passe en
seine-saint-denis la géopolitique de la
chine pirates ski c'est aux éditions
eyrolles
c'est bien ça et les nouveaux enfants du
siècle alexandre de véhicules ces taux
servent
il y en a un autre qui est en
préparation oui sans doute le mouvement
populiste
on l'attend on les attend avec
impatience dans une heure vous avez
également rendez vous ici dans ce
plateau 6 sur figaro live avec audition
publique l'attelage l'émission qui est
présenté avec la chambre pâle
parlementaire public sénat et la fp
l'invité et marc chesneau le nouveau
ministre des relations avec le parlement
et demain vous retrouver guillaume marc
fesneau pardon demain vous retrouver
guillaume roquette et là le nom n'est
pas écorché
[Musique]